noch nie enthielt werbung so viel
wahrheit wie recht die damen haben
der vw up gas skandal sprengt alle
bisher bekannten beschiss dimensionen 12
millionen autos weltweit wurden
manipuliert
die schäden an der umwelt noch kann sie
niemand beziffern
dabei wollte volkswagen doch zu den
guten gehören innovativ nachhaltig und
umweltbewusst bemüht um ein gutes
betriebsklima fair zu den arbeitnehmern
gute geschäfte statt profit ohne ende
hohe ethische standards und marktführer
beim dienst am kunden
im nachhaltigkeitsbericht 2014 steht es
geschrieben
bis 2018 will der volkswagen-konzern als
weltweite nummer eins an der
ökologischen spitze der
automobilhersteller stehen
die wirklichkeit sieht aber anders aus
die ngo erklärung von bern gehört zu den
globalisierungskritischen beobachtern
international tätiger konzerne die sich
gerne ähnlich wie volkswagen nicht als
jährige profit geyer sondern als
engelsgleiche wohltäter darstellen
immer mehr konzerne prahlen mit ihren
ethischen grundsätzen und
geschäftspraktiken nicht der profit soll
im vordergrund stehen sondern ihr
soziales engagement in der
globalisierten welt
keine kinderarbeit keine verschmutzung
der umwelt
keine ausbeutung von arbeitskraft
corporate social responsibility nennt
sich das in der sprache der ökonomen
freiwillig ohne staatlichen zwang will
man die welt von oben verändern
auf einem markt der neben dem streben
nach gewinn auch menschliche züge tragen
soll
nachfolgende generationen ist
kurzfristige profite
das ist ein alter
globalisierungskritische ort das ist
klar aber mach es nicht nur zeigt dass
die logik wachstums logik damit die
globalisierungs logik vor denen
megakonzern natürlich ein zu stoßen das
zeigt vw wachstum und immer höhere
gewinne bei gleichzeitig hohen ethischen
zielen
da scheint die kollision unvermeidlich
lässt der markt die moral verkümmern
ja sagt die ökonomen novacek der markt
verführt zu unmoralischem tun und sie
begründet diese these mit den
ergebnissen eines brisanten experiments
das sie gemeinsam mit ihrem kollegen
armin falk in bonn durchgeführt hat
1000 testpersonen wurden vor die
entscheidung gestellt wollen sie zehn
euro oder das leben einer maus wer sich
für das geld entscheidet nimmt
gleichzeitig den tod der maus in kauf
alleine nur auf sich gestellt
entschieden sich 46 prozent für das geld
die maus wurde getötet
danach wurde eine marktsituation
hergestellt ein verkäufer und mehrere
käufer konnten handeln den preis unter
sich ausmachen
wenn nur einer nein sagte blieb die maus
am leben trotzdem 72 prozent entschieden
sich für das geld
in der studie mussten alle teilnehmer
ganz genau was sie entscheiden und sie
haben auch gesehen wie der tus prozess
aussieht für ihre maus wenn sie sich
dafür entscheiden es gab ein video und
jeder hatte das gesehen
und trotzdem war es so dass in den markt
situationen die moralischen werte in den
keller ging die marktsituation der fokus
auf den profit die soziale information
das teilen von schuld es macht es
leichter egoistisch zu werden markt
moral
ein ungleiches paar und je mehr menschen
involviert sind wie in einem großen
unternehmen desto mehr verteilt sich die
verantwortung bis sie sich gänzlich
verflüchtigt
doch nach außen gilt der schöne schein
diese